[Musique]
[Applaudissements] la
nuit descend sur la route 180 dans le nord
du Nouveau-Brunswick autour de nous se trouve la
silhouette familière de la forêt à feuilles persistantes c'est
un homme fait pour nous sur lequel des dizaines de
milliers de kilogrammes de glyphosate sont
pulvérisés chaque année pas pour un public dont la
compagnie  c'est du diesel plein de ressentiment qu'on dise à
propos des frais de dépôt de fourrure peon a chanté
super serré et un chef de protocole c'est
une histoire de pesticides mais c'est aussi
de l'exploitation des terres publiques l'
influence et la censure c'est une histoire
qui commence ici dans la petite
communauté acadienne de Ketchikan  depuis plus de 25 ans,
la famille Apple organise des
expéditions en canoë sur la rivière Goosh hâtive ses
eaux cristallines sont reconnues
dans le monde entier comme une destination de pêche au saumon
depuis des décennies la région a
attiré des milliers de touristes
Villopoto G prendre soin de cette région
est devenu un  grand combat pour eux
pour la France à Lévesque et André Appa
ce qui était autrefois leur paradis s'est transformé
en désolation à seulement cinq kilomètres
de leur maison jusqu'à 100
grumiers passent ici tous les jours imaginez l'
odeur beaucoup à l'avance c'est ce qu'il est venu il est
déjà venu il est déjà venu vous savez
c'est triste la technologie Filippo les jeunes
sources de fans les gens une telle convenance limiter
l'industrie forestière est un secteur clé dans
l'économie du nouveau-brunswick génère
près de deux milliards de dollars en retombées
cette petite province pulvérise plus de
glyphosate par acre de forêt publique que
toute autre au canada depuis des années le biologiste
marque à la télé rit a suivi cet
écosystème forestier des bois de Silverland
nous avons terminé une grande marche vérifié  sortir pour
un répit une ménagerie il est temps boue la
forêt il commande un cadeau comme si la
pomme de terre apprécie nos fruits de mer canada
cette gestion forestière s'accompagne de deux
pratiques controversées la première est la
coupe à blanc qui est répandue au nouveau
brunswick et a de graves conséquences écologiques
la seconde  est l'utilisation généralisée d'un
glyphosate chimique cet herbicide est
pulvérisé en moyenne 15 000 h  ectares
de forêt coupée chaque année,
il tue les feuillus, ce qui laisse la place à
des conifères plus rentables pour faire pousser un
outil utile pour l'industrie, mais pour d'autres, un
poison de Sandy Cohen femme
problème de silice P la subin est en dessous de Hosanna
Hosanna ennemis Sacramento entier qz est
un favori à tout moment et  coulé est une
carte postale unique voir c'est entre 2013 et
2017 cette région était la plus pulvérisée de
la province n'était pas confortable vous voyez
faire pour un pauvre 12 watts des gens de partout dans
un comté de st gross ont formé le groupe
eco V ils disent la santé  de leurs
forêts et les gens qui vivent autour d'
elle sont en danger ils ont de mauvais souvenirs de l'utilisation du
DDT dans ces régions les truies
me jouent c'est une photo de vous
va là-bas pour ne pas mettre en commun
Mateus a avancez Vasiliy vérifiez un autre à
propos de vous accostez  là,
restez bas et ils se méfient du glyphosate,
nous avons ceci et - j'aimerais être dans le
désert de la carte des homicides Tabernacle moi
qui est le service du travail de notre société Oh m.
temple donc le gars Thomas jeune pasteur
qu'il pouvait faire du katana juste je vais
verser le filet profond est particulier pour mettre
le genou en contexte c'est pourquoi je
respecte je dois dire que tu étais membre fondateur
d'écho V il était candidat pour
le vert  Parti lors de la dernière
élection provinciale il a produit une série en ligne sur
l'état des forêts de la couronne au Nouveau-
Brunswick tu manques Alyssa a poussé dont les
yeux tario a été l'un des premiers à se
demander comment les herbicides étaient utilisés oh
ils sont rencontrés avec un mascara pour être
monogame  Je compte un degré Fassett et
impacter Epsom en colère pas salé Israël
agressé pas étranger donc pour
être persécuté soit la diversité joue au kebab la
garantie du profit de l'entreprise sa
femme Betty Sam Pierre tu travailles
toujours pour toujours l'émotion non est-ce qu'il peut
convaincre tara de faire ses valises comment  facile les fans
qui sont les plus élites gratuits réversibles
il sera ils ont observé
des changements importants dans la forêt autour d'
eux
jebin McCain a été une politique euh les fourmis
marchent le plus c'est rencontré les miles d'avion  où
j'allais bien Shauna où cette feuille de vol pur Anton a-t-elle
déterminé si ma
mère a-
t-elle défié vu si vous avez quatre ans, les
citoyens ont appelé à la fin de la
pulvérisation sur les terres de la Couronne, mais ils n'ont pas
été en mesure de modifier les pratiques de l'industrie
exception pour  un PC la ville de l'installation a fait
plus comme un outil social downs in Fashion
Week Amasya Mike ledger est
directeur exécutif de Forest New Brunswick la
voix de l'industrie forestière dans la
province
si le gouvernement approuve l'utilisation du glyphosate
, il dit que l'industrie peut le
pulvériser  directement une
occasion de verrouillage glamour aujourd'hui alimenter directement pour les ensembles une
presse techniquement seulement feriez-vous
fidélité ou Sydney quelle que soit la province
ouais donc c'est légal la
pulvérisation de glyphosate a un
impact significatif sur l'environnement dit makan
kabila le biologiste a enseigné pendant plus de
vingt ans à l'Université du
Montana et sait  la forêt acadienne,
il dit que les pratiques forestières intensives
ont un impact négatif sur la
capacité des forêts à  régénérer dans certains
Cappuccio sur-complimenter la capacité d'apprentissage de
Letitia st y un compromiso tempo SI
su psychologique par exemple les Arabes les plus récents
conquis sont Esposito comme O'Keefe Raina
Karim Allah signifie ma la plage de
Plantation
Sun flamboyant EDD placer un voyage
Atlantis afin de conférer les besoins de la forêt  une riche
biodiversité pour se maintenir et se
régénérer cela garantit également que la
forêt pourra être récoltée à l'avenir,
mais l'industrie ne partage pas ce point de vue le
soutien de Neos un véritable saint des joueurs
mais etc boxeur encore une fois sauver un ilha da da
vitesse donnée sur la surface de la plantation
un aéroport européen de façade mais ce n'est pas
ce que le travail de makan AVL révèle son
réaliste sur la caste infectée prise lors
des manifestations vous savez quelque part simplement
parabolique ivenna - ils ne parabolent pas les
abus ce costume de cirque voir le
tapis roulant ou le pacte de conception Prince là
dr.  Marc André dar est un biologiste il
me rejoint de notre moine au studio Vila n'est
pas le seul à défier l'industrie de la
tige Cumberland a payé le prix fort pour
ses avis sur l'entorse au glyphosate
vous aimeriez voir des gens qui ont un
peu de force intestinale  mais je
ne sais pas si nous semblons manquer de cela
dans cette province et si vous en avez, vous
vous retrouvez dans la ligne du chômage
attaquer l'industrie forestière au Nouveau-
Brunswick n'est pas sans risques
pendant 15 ans rod cumberland a été l'un des
les experts de la faune les plus fiables
, mais c'était avant qu'il ne
critique l'utilisation du glyphosate sur les terres
de la Couronne, car le biologiste provincial du cerf
Cumberland avait l'habitude de suivre les animaux, de
suivre leurs mouvements et il
surveillait leur habitat d'hiver un jour,
quelque chose d'inhabituel a attiré son attention
et tout d'un coup  la moitié de nos actions se sont
réveillées, donc mes questions à l'époque étaient les
gars bien plus élevés, nos parcs à cerfs sont
vacants, nous les gardons pour ces moments,
il n'y a pas de numéro de cerf, personne de nouveau
[Musique]
cumbe  rland s'attendait à trouver des cerfs
dans les zones de coupe à blanc de la forêt où les
bois se régénèrent naturellement j'ai été
surpris de ce que nous avons trouvé
67% de toutes ces zones de régénération que
tout le monde pensait être pleines de nourriture pour les cerfs
pour les plantations et elles ont été pulvérisées
avec de l'herbicide le  l'herbicide tue
les arbres et les arbustes à feuilles caduques dont les cerfs ont
besoin pour survivre une fois pulvérisés.
le bateau ici comme j'ai été choqué,
cela explique pourquoi, selon
Cumberland, les chantiers de cerfs sont maintenant
vides, ses 32 000 tonnes de cerfs, c'est
ce que 300 camions à benne remplis de nourriture pour cerfs,
comme parlons chiffres, ce que nous
pulvérisons en un an nourrira plus d'un tiers
de  le troupeau actuel de cerfs dont il
existe des chiffres assez choquants,
n'est-ce pas après sa retraite alors que le
biologiste provincial du cerf Cumberland a
commencé à dénoncer la
pulvérisation de glyphosate
nous avons sauvé tous ces chantiers de cerfs pourquoi n'y a-
t-il pas de cerfs dans les chantiers de cerfs mais ses
données scientifiques ont été remises en question ses
opinions attaquées comme citation irresponsable
les accusations provenaient de JD Erving le
plus grand acteur de l'industrie forestière de la province
la société appartient à l'un des
les familles les plus riches du Canada avec de
grandes exploitations dans les médias pétroliers et d'autres
industries
Irving gère plus de 10 000
kilomètres carrés de terres publiques et
défend fermement ses pratiques basées sur des années
et des décennies d'expérience en
gestion forestière la famille a
estimé que la meilleure pratique nous permettait de
c'est à travers ces pratiques dont
vous parlez
qu'Irving défend non seulement son travail, mais qu'il
veut maintenant plus de terres, il demande plus d'
accès aux zones de conservation de connexion
habitat mis de côté pour protéger la faune
vous savez forêts de feuillus matures cours de cerfs
bandes tampons  toutes ces zones dont
nous avions besoin pour la gestion des poissons et de la
faune constituaient essentiellement la
conversation parce qu'elles avaient cu  t
tout le reste, donc tout ce qui restait était
cette terre de crime à 30% et ils le voulaient,
la famille Irving a ce qui semble être
une influence considérable dans une lettre
au premier ministre
Irving a menacé de supprimer des emplois si l'
entreprise n'avait pas accès à ces
zones de conservation  Bruce Northrop, le
ministre des Ressources naturelles de l'époque,
s'est opposé à ce que l'entreprise se connecte dans ces
zones.
Irving a déposé une plainte quelques semaines
plus tard, Northrup a été transféré à un autre
portefeuille. Je ne pense pas que certaines personnes
me voulaient dans ce département et,
évidemment, c'était un premier ministre.  d'autres jours,
la décision de mise à la terre a exaucé son souhait le
gouvernement a accepté de revoir la taille des
zones de conservation en fonction de ce que la
société forestière voulait une entente qu'elle a d'
abord tenté de garder secrète
[Musique]
les gens du Nouveau-Brunswick ont ​​finalement
découvert que leur forêt de conservation
serait  être réduit à seulement 23% définir une
clarinette ouais effet néphrons Sigma
Masha le lac sur le pionnier Vénus
accompagnera le dénominationnel Irving était
heureux qui chère Jennifer Adnan est un
FSO
aujourd'hui réponse à une nouvelle obligation monétaire
Rocco travaille avec l'Université
pour des recherches plus approfondies concerne Alec
callate the Sea Islands l'un des
membres du comité consultatif scientifique de mise à la terre
était les biologistes makanda Vela il
n'est pas d'accord il a publiquement critiqué le nouveau
politique vous êtes très franc ici
y a-t-il des conséquences pour cela en ce qui
concerne JT Jessica de la balance
le renard scooty l'estimation des exportations et
voyez si su lis terriblement nous ne pouvons pas abroger
le terriblement nous et l'inquiétude peut venir à coup
sûr
étonnez-moi six premium Shasha
Pasco graves effets Amanda voyage et
toute la journée sur Sol est un estimateur fédéral
voir désolé deuxième typique surpris MSRP
Sgt éjecter sa qualité après que la marque sur
lourd ait maintenant été expulsée après la
destitution du ministre, c'était les
médecins en chef des provinces tournés
de perdre soudainement son emploi, elle a été licenciée au
moment même où elle commençait à se pencher sur l'utilisation
du glyphosate,
son licenciement était immédiat  nté comme un
problème de ressources humaines, il y a eu plus d'
indignation publique lorsque le vérificateur général a
critiqué le gouvernement pour ses
pratiques forestières obsolètes et le coût élevé pour les
contribuables de ces pratiques.
un panneau jpg remercie
Sasa contrôles et cette paire Sahn pop
quiz sur les palookas low Safia honnête alors que l'
opposition montait dans la province un nouveau
groupe appelé stop spraying New Brunswick
est né puis en 2015 l'industrie a été
prise par surprise le
glyphosate a été classé comme
cancérigène probable par  le Centre international
de recherche sur le cancer les
entreprises forestières ont riposté rapidement en collaboration
avec le gouvernement, ils ont lancé le
site Web forest info point CA pour éduquer
le public sur la méthode du glyphosate afin que vous
voyiez un Optimus keynésien donc hôtel modiere
pour moi laissez-vous réparer un bouton comprar si se
puede junkie  trabaja frac paddies a
expiré [ __ ] pour evo formance Opunake
jusqu'à présent, vous méritez un énorme  Les
informations de forest info point ca sont soutenues par
LAN Ritter, professeur émérite à l'
Université de Guelph et expert bien connu
, de sorte que les types d'
herbicides utilisés varient d'une application à l'autre
, mais celui qui a attiré
le plus d'attention ici au Nouveau-
Brunswick en particulier a  été
glyphosate des mots rassurants peut-être mais un
langage que les Canadiens ont entendu
avant que des pesticides ne soient pulvérisés sur
la forêt canadienne depuis plus de 60 ans l'un
des plus dangereux était sans aucun doute à
450 un produit chimique qui contient des dioxines et
considéré comme un puissant cancérigène Agent
Orange un mélange rapide et sale de  deux
herbicides 2 4 D et le beaucoup plus
puissant à 450 c'est l'un des
ingrédients de l'Agent Orange le tristement célèbre
produit chimique défoliant utilisé par l'
armée américaine pendant la guerre du Vietnam que les
États-Unis ont baguée à la fin des années 70 mais
Santé Canada a continué d'approuver son
utilisation jusqu'à  le milieu des années 1980 JD
mais 800 gallons de ce problème Irving a
ensuite acheté 800 gallons du p  esticide
et l'a pulvérisé sur les forêts du Nouveau-
Brunswick l'un des toxicologues de
Santé Canada à l'époque était Len Ritter
Ritter est considéré comme une
autorité respectée et il a souvent défendu l'
utilisation de pesticides et d'autres produits chimiques,
il a également été sévèrement critiqué pour
ses positions en 2011  lorsque l'Ontario l'a
choisi pour mener une enquête sur les travailleurs
exposés à l'agent Orange,
comment avez-vous pu nommer quelqu'un pour le
diriger qui travaillait pour le
ministère même où ils autoriseront l'utilisation de l'
agent Orange et qui en est finalement devenu le
chef à ce moment-là?  enquête pour
recommander une nouvelle controverse qui n'est pas familière à
Massey, bien sûr considéré comme des preuves dans des
pseudo-hommes regardez vous avez déjà
réalisé que je peux traverser voir pas un problème Le
nom de Len Reuters apparaît également dans les
papiers de Monsanto ce sont des
documents internes publiés dans des procédures judiciaires américaines
Ritter faisait partie  d'une liste d'
experts sur lesquels Monsanto a estimé pouvoir compter
pour défendre le glyphosate, il est
décrit par le fabricant comme certains  celui
qui livre les interprétations et les
messages que l'on veut faire passer sur
le sujet le
professeur Ritter n'a pas répondu à nos
questions forest info dot CA est également
soutenu par des chercheurs qui ont travaillé
avec le ministère fédéral des
Ressources naturelles responsable de
communiquer ce que nous sommes  faire dans
les bois et pourquoi ils défendent
la position de l'industrie toutes ces données mènent
à la conclusion cohérente et cela ne
s'oppose pas à un risque environnemental ou à un
risque pour les espèces sauvages certains de leurs
travaux ont été financés par des
fabricants de pesticides, y compris Monsanto ainsi
que par Irving  soutenez tous soyez normalement
beaucoup scientifique quelque part
des boutiques de souvenirs une capsule de souvenirs une entreprise
qui ou des poches avaient parce qu'un camion de démonstration
cam scientifique à cause de tout clair et
plaisir et soyez nous là-bas
téléchargez elle-même les liens entre Monsanto
Irving et les chercheurs ne sont pas
divulgués sur  le biologiste du site Web
McConaughey Vela admet que certains de
ses travaux et ceux de son  les étudiants ont été
partiellement financés par Irving que le financement a
été coupé lorsque Villa a été expulsée de son
comité scientifique
Irving a refusé de répondre à nos questions
le compagnon accepte certains points le
contrôle est son public mon nom Yannick
et le professeur Eshel Elliott académique
ne s'associent pas pour acceptable selon
forest info point CA ne fait aucune mention du
travail du Laos sur l'impact négatif de
la foresterie intensive sur la biodiversité
qu'est-ce que la forêt dans l'information forcée point CA est de la
propagande directement c'est de la
propagande c'était un site Web créé pour essentiellement
contrer pour faire savoir aux gens que
tout va bien  avec du glyphosate en
juin 2019, Rod Cumberland a été renvoyé du
collège maritime de
technologie forestière où il enseignait depuis
sept ans l'une des raisons invoquées pour
son licenciement ma position à ce sujet s'appelle
saper la science dans le séminaire
de gestion de la végétation les gens ne
réalisent pas  c'est mon point de vue sur le
glyphosate
un ancien directeur exécutif du
collège  dit qu'il s'est senti obligé pendant
son mandat de faire taire Cumberland a ressenti de la
pression pour essayer de sanctionner Rod pour son
franc-parler l'ancien directeur qui
occupait toujours un poste d'enseignant au
collège a également été licencié
Cumberland est dans une position précaire,
il vit de deux petits contrats, il y a
des problèmes pratiques comme nous avons perdu notre Croix Bleue,
donc tout ce pour quoi nous étions couverts pour l'
instant est parti du jour au lendemain, c'est tout un
combat là-bas et bien sûr,
ça a gâché ma pension
mais il ne regrette rien  Le Nouveau-Brunswick n'est
pas la seule province à utiliser le glyphosate
presque toutes les provinces canadiennes ont
adopté la pratique mais pas le Québec
où les citoyens se sont battus avec acharnement contre l'
industrie pour interdire l'herbicide
[Musique]
pas ici pour un
artisan stratégique humaniste naturel accompagné de
reporters devenus développeurs ontologiques
motifs que jeune mère il y a environ 20
ans artiste poisson et danse asiatique
docume  ntary a conduit à de grands changements dans les
pratiques de l'industrie forestière au Québec à l'époque où
cette province avait déjà adopté une
mesure révolutionnaire la fin de la pulvérisation aérienne d'
herbicides la plupart des sondages sont comme
esto pour quasi T Benny
Silla politique est un caucus voir le
faucon maimie sont pris sur le  mur brunswick a
dit que vous populisme les examens sont la
marque d'un coup d'État dans une certaine réverbération elizalde
pour la masse et a signalé qu'il considérait son
budget ou non une affaire pas l'équité du fil
ou pas et réduire défaire mémoire
seulement zip vous voyez géométriquement [ __ ]
monsieur Luke butin a est  l'homme responsable
de l'interdiction il a dirigé l'
enquête provinciale sur les impacts environnementaux qui a
recommandé la fin de la pulvérisation aérienne
d'herbicides l'interdiction est entrée en vigueur
en 2001 avant que la province ait pendant des
années pulvérisé ces produits chimiques dangereux
sur ses sanyaasi les plus pauvres le nouveau rafael
lucu DDT  décapiterait sancti ducat
teto Kasane teto puisque la langue de la cuisine
ne dira pas bae yong un paradigme la
végétation Bhavan dans le re  port
résistance à l'impact vitesse pivoines asthme
sahaja dieu non non Yan absent
pendant les audiences l'
industrie agrochimique forestiers scientifiques
écologistes et citoyens ont tous eu l'
occasion de donner leur avis yato bgg
bomberos - nikki à tino zapatti d'accord
ouais manifeste nachiketa eNOS vieil homme a vu
une application d'actualités  encore une fois, le faux
Québec a remplacé la pulvérisation aérienne par
un nettoyage mécanique au sol, une
option plus coûteuse mais qui a créé des emplois
qui, à Oscar gee, j'ai vu Secret Santa
Moscow, alors maintenant je suis un sportif des économies
et je suis renversé qui empêche l'
industrie forestière  au Nouveau-Brunswick dit qu'il
ne peut pas être compétitif sans herbicides
oh cher Casey Anup ou manque d'un et la
clé est chanceuse pour que nous restions une
priorité complète maintenant ils sont productifs
souveraineté sociale ce qui est routinier comme
quantité de guerre une guerre civile pour pour  Neil
OCD lors de l'utilisation d'un port-a-potty
un emploi sur quatre dans la province
dépend de la foresterie dans de nombreuses petites
communautés, les gens ont peur de perdre
leurs emplois
ripostent Deborah assise encore plus, nous
pouvons comprendre juste la vie d'école d'été une
chanson a commencé en envoyant Fiona
courir la nuit quand Villa - nous ciblons seulement
nous espérons que vous voyagez - oui pas étonnant parce que
je suis impatient de tango girly non probablement
tu vois  J'y vais, mais
malgré les manifestations, les pétitions, même une
tentative de déposer une motion à l'
assemblée législative provinciale, rien n'a
changé, le gouvernement est dirigé par un
premier ministre qui est également le chef de l'exploitation des huiles urbaines
, je vous dirai que la
province a été capturée par des
intérêts commerciaux.  oh ouais je vais chercher la
population ici, il est parti une police et sur
l'Avanti de Stockholm une loterie très
acceptante qui a fait qu'un homme monte sur le
capitaine benevelon personnel
donne Antonia homme capitale de la ville e dit P oh
merde l'homme ne cherche que la perruque de la femme suppose
oh garçon j'ai gardé  jusqu'à la folie un travail j'ai
gardé le plus récent de mmm déficit
officiel seulement mi-entreprise est al période e SQ
bucolique acceptabilité observable alors elle
Al Khalifa ha ha
w  hich cher un homme présent depuis jeune
question alors 24 Brunswick vous permettez une
consultation
John éternellement lézard camp de milice dégingandé
onyx un sermon dans minou
le maire feuille de cuivre idiot ce sont des
canoës de formation à propos de ce n'est
pas assez
Frederick butin un soutien dans le dommage
oh  ouais gardien Halliburton Peleg un
secret mon être écoute famille nous voyons des
commandes un conjoint des voleurs expliquent
environ moi pour être tellement pour baiser ma conscience
SEPA âme acceptabilité sociale
quelqu'un à propos de Saudia ainsi qu'il ne sera pas
sombre à tout le moins les opposants au Nouveau-
Brunswick veulent  le gouvernement de suivre
l'exemple du Québec et d'utiliser le
principe de précaution mostró que tous les
groupies du jour d'Irvin s'opposent à Ella
Forrester même le cas épique épique de l'
exportation une ressource judicata
répressive la précaution intrusive un
auskey sur le double argument est nosotros
Kira's Cantor Poulos a mis les étudiants figlo
mais je  'll do it arrête une sœur, alors
professeur, nous ne devrions pas être injustes, nous
ne sommes pas envers vous mais copublions  euh apprends que
toi
à Keswick la forêt akkadienne dégrade lentement les
choses rock sur le chalet Judy
Lac il - je n'ai jamais pris un poblano pour faire un
mec aérien c'était bon ta nourriture mais une
parcelle a été épargnée et a reçu la
protection du gouvernement non non tu vois  J'ai
rebondi l'entraîneur voir le café nous quittons
les urgences v le dois-je sonner une fois que
vous passerez tout ce que le professeur
cadonia fait résume sa propre pétition qui,
au regret
que nous ayons quitté le Nouveau-Brunswick, nous n'avons pas pu nous
empêcher de nous demander si le public  la forêt
appartenait encore au public
toi